okay well first of all congratulations
on the stand it is fantastic
um i know that the series was in
production here in canada when the
pandemic hit
and then you know things got shut down
for a few days so what were your
reactions like
given that real life was imitating art
in this way it's weird timing
it's weird timing um but i think there's
a lot that isn't
you know there's a lot about our series
which is about um
you know heightened circumstances yes
yes
takes place after pandemic wipes out uh
you know most of humanity but
it the series isn't really about that
it's about what we do
want with it it's about what we do after
that and that's what makes it
interesting it's about what we do
with the ruins and you know the loss
that we
have and the broken humans that occupy
this space of trying to rebuild
a normal world or new normal of a world
and
you know it's about the humanity of like
how we define ourselves and what we what
we are going to make of each
of ourselves what about you joe
um no i think you know it's interesting
because
as amber said when we were finishing
production
the pandemic in reality was kind of just
starting to gear up
at least you know over on this side of
the tracks and uh
i have to say i didn't take it
i didn't think it was gonna i didn't
think we were gonna be where we are now
i can definitely say that like i was
still
not to compare it to captain trips
because it is something completely
different
but just being in in a place where
you're surrounded by people like if you
go to the doctor or whatever
people surrounded in hamza or yeah has
met suits or what have you
that was something that is like man it's
a bit it's a bit trippy and it's
see what i did there it was an accident
captured uh no it's
it was weird it was weird to kind of
witness but uh
yeah i don't i don't know how to answer
that it's just weird well
all i know is i would have been scared
as hell if i was doing this show
and the next thing you know everything
got shut down i've been like what when
we mean got to the end we had like a
couple things to shoot left but we got
through all the filming
before we actually started seeing stuff
that's happening now
we kind of got through it so i mean i
don't know amber you had to go back so
i would have been tripped out yeah yeah
i mean it is it's kind of it's strange
but i think it's part of what makes it
interesting is that this show
um kind of forces you to ask yourself
those big questions like what would i do
like what would i do and i think all of
us if in 2020 have gotten
a moment to appreciate that or at least
ask ourselves that's like
what who are you you know despite
incredible circumstances
among you know incredibly difficult
choices and
obstacles who are you and what would you
do
despite all that yeah i love that
um amber for you i know your character
she's quite a conflicted woman
you know dealing with the struggle
between good and evil but she becomes a
caregiver for a young boy named joe
would you say the struggle is real for
nadine in this
[Laughter]
struggle is so real it is so real
she i mean she's got in many ways she's
the most tragic of all the characters
she's put in an almost impossible
situation where she does have a choice
ultimately at the end of the day
but it's not really a a it's not a fair
choice it's certainly
um more nuanced and difficult than most
in that she
has been you know set up her whole life
and groomed her whole life to get to
this
point and she reaches that point right
after kind of meeting larry
and the other characters that live in
the boulder-free zone
and experiencing for the first time in
her life actual love and relationships
and right when she gets there
she's forced to make the ultimate
decision
the ultimate sacrifice and um you know
world hasn't been kind to nadine you
almost can't
blame her for not you know not
expecting the world to be anything
better um now that
these you know it the slate's been wiped
yeah
hard yeah well thank you guys for your
time
y'all have fun now be safe thank you
appreciate it
bye guys thank you
you